accueillir servi aux conseillers commis
de cuisine barman serveur les métiers de
l'hôtellerie restauration
ici une vingtaine de jeunes tout juste
formé ils ont la lourde charge de tenir
d'un bout à l'autre
l'organisation d'un cocktail près de 150
invités
j'ai pu par une formation de bas en est
qui fait en sorte que maintenant je suis
complète dans l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est à dire ben mon bac qui est en
panne générale et technologique ranhôtel
restauration c'est un bac qui refermait
de géantes de gérant de salle de cuisine
en gros c'est soit je serai chef de haut
rang ou chefs de cuisine des jeunes
formés par l'umih l'union des métiers et
des industries de l'hôtellerie
ce sont des formations diplômantes mais
qui se veulent pratico pratique ces
déformations métier qui passe minimum
70% du temps sur leurs futurs postes de
travail c'est pour ça qu'on à l'hôtel
batelière en fait qui est agréé pour
être notre hôtel école parce que du coup
dès le début de formation
ils sont vraiment directement derrière
un bar ou un service en salle en
situations trois ou quatre mois de
formation et à la clé des cdd et cdi
pour répondre aux besoins actuels du
secteur du tourisme